hey what's up fellow Geeks today we have
a special job from Bandai and it's the
currency score Final Fantasy 7 reunion
hero Edition so we'll open it up right
now
[Music]
okay so we get a card box inside which
is simple but you know what they say
Simplicity is beauty also because it's
later so there's that inside
[Music]
so this is the box that we get is the
crisis called Final Fantasy reunion so
we get everyone's favorite second class
Soldier Zack fair so you can see this is
not the master sword I believe it's the
sword that he got before he acquired the
master sword from Angel so we'll open it
up to see what's on the inside oh it's
my boy is that fair
if you see the actual my boy here the
actor figurine and we will be opening up
to play around with it
it's a big big
there are like some motifs here like you
can see it's the sword so there is a
nice touch to just a plain cup plastic
cover okay so now that we've got the
figurines let's get down to it
of course the most obvious one would be
[Applause]
like unwrapping it
um do take note that the plastic is
actually kind of like
but it's inside his uniform so it will
take a while for you to fully remove the
plastic which is why I am struggling
oh my God
now that all the plastic has been
removed we can go on and accessorize him
oh he's dead okay so we have hands
it's very handy and then we have the oh
the holding kind of hands the different
kind of pants the one that he will hold
to the sword then we have the sword the
sword itself it's not the Buster sword
so if you all know the exact name of it
you can give it the comments below but
for now according
I believe this is to swap out
the blades I think really see yeah let
me see here it doesn't really look that
different from what we have so it might
just be an extra blade what's up
everybody Zaki from the future editing
this video and this two swash that
you're seeing one of them has a bump so
they can fit it at the back of Zach and
the other one is just without the bum so
that Zack can hold it and you'll see it
later in this video and there's the
second layer so these are the
accessories to hold this figurine up
once you're done with the customizing
you can use these to support him
standing up sorry my hand cream oh my
God
if you are no well versed with the
figurines you will know that you can
move the arms around yeah it's Palm it's
Palm my hand okay so uh you have the
left and right articulate
the hair is spiky like sex extra hair in
the game yeah the you can see the
suspenders the one that he wears is the
soldier uniform in the game and yeah you
can also swap out the arms so we'll do a
quick swap there's actually the left
side and the right side of the hand so
when you swap out you will have to be
careful because I was confused earlier
as well so this is the right I believe
yeah
so yep I can swap it up it's very easy
you just have to pull and plug same
thing goes for the left just have to
make sure that you pick the right one
same thing uh plug put in and you're
done so the special thing about the
sword is that you can actually put it on
the back of the model
um but do take note that you will have
to use something to pry open oh I'm
sorry Zach please um rest in peace um
yeah so you have to use something we are
using a knife here to pry it open
this short version with the one with the
bomb at the back you have to put this on
then you can
yep there you go so this is what you get
at the back swap out the blade as well
put on the other one
this time you have to pluck out the base
and put it in the arms
this is what you get in front
so if you're worried that the salt will
come off while eating his hands um it's
actually quite tight so it takes a lot
of Austin will be actually whoa yeah so
it will be secure so you don't have to
worry about it so if you want to hold
him up that's what the accessories that
we showed you earlier is for oh pry open
okay that's it weird I don't know if
he's supposed to stand on like flat
ground or not there you go it took a
while but here's Zach standing proud and
tall
my favorite part about this figure is
the detail that went into the whole
thing so you can see the gloss on the
pens on the shoes as well as the hair I
think the spikes actually bring out the
whole prickly feeling you get with spiky
hair and you get it here and the best
part about it is actually for the salt
being able to be placed on the back
because that's the signature pose of
black so it's nice to see it here and if
you're not a fan of it you can always
play it on the front sing the sword
around with the joint articulation
lastly the stand helps to prop him up so
you don't really have problem with
stability so that's a good touch and now
that our boys deck pair is set up and
all ready to go I just got reminded that
crisis call will also be heading to PC
and what better way to play crisis calls
than on an MSI laptop this video is
brought to you by MSI meet the summit
e16 flip featuring the latest 12th gen
Intel Core i7 processor RTX 30 series
graphics and a 16 inch Quad HD Plus
touchscreen panel with a 360 degree
hinge it lets you unleash maximum
productivity with up to 11 hours of
battery life at just 2 kilograms the
Sami e16 flip offers unprecedented
performance and functionality allowing
you to work and play any anywhere
anytime now let's see what else is
inside
we have a very thick book we will open
it up I think it's a book but it could
be a script book as well based on past
experiences so we'll open it up and see
what's inside just gonna see how I can
open stuff so we have this events do not
remove any suit one thick boy oh wait we
actually have a CD here is that first on
the front we see him here and then the
back is a catalog of six songs that you
can find in the disk here open up the
remaining
so there's also a letter inside when you
open it up you see
flowers you know what this means it
means the letter is from Irish to Zach I
believe so if you open that is in
Japanese so it's yeah it's too SEC from
what I can see from the letter it's a
very informal letter from Aries
um to Jack talking about the flowers and
something about cake shop but it's a
very nice touch because it has Aries
signature
speaking manner in the game it's very
informal and can feel like the dynamic
between her and Zach that translates to
the game
all right yes this is a book so Heroes
pass in prison let's open it so you can
see this is the cover it's hard cover
so there's a great touch on inside oh
Buster sword
yeah so you can see the trio
now you can see everything Zach
and yeah it's just bits and pieces of it
there's the prologue from the game from
the locals the play that Genesis to the
game
I believe they sort by characters so you
get exact first they get in jail
Genesis yep so this is just a taste of
what the art book offers and lastly yep
we got the scriptbook it's in Japanese
there are some illustrations to go with
um each of the chapters so it's mainly
just Japanese and then you get stuff
like that so it denotes the chapter for
each
this is
for people who are into the behind the
scenes stuff and that's what we have
this is what we have for the unboxing
for crisis called Final Fantasy 7
reunion please keep in mind that this is
only for consumers in Asia so if there
are different regions your contents May
differ if you enjoy watching this video
do give us a like And subscribe to our
Channel it goes a long way if you like
this video check this out
[Music]
do do do
do do do do do do do do do do do do do
do do do do do do do
do do